let's get to audience questions for the
week first question hey David what do
you think should be Democrats version of
repeal and replace Obamacare for the
2018 midterms right so Republicans for a
while I I don't even know that it was
just in one election but for a very long
time Republicans have been on this
refrain of repeal and replace Obamacare
of course they never did it when
President Obama was president what
should be the version of that for
Democrats the obvious one is sticking
with health care Medicare for all now
can they get Medicare for all through
even if they take over the House and
Senate in 2018 unclear is that likely to
happen absolutely not
but I think the idea of it as a sort of
rallying cry is a pretty good idea we
know that Medicare for all is polling
increasingly well with the entire
country and really for me it relates to
the issue of economic fairness and an
economy that works I would like to say
for everybody but ideally for more
people and Medicare for all is sort of
one component of that when we talk about
huge inequality when we talk about
concentration of wealth and income and
assets when we talk about lack of access
to healthcare and social services and
the negative externalities of people not
having access to healthcare Medicare for
all is a great slogan but it's really a
conduit to the broader message of
economic justice that I see is a really
important one for Democrats so I think
Medicare for all is great as a slogan
because it will inspire people to go out
and vote it's a will up ulis message
yeah I think so because health care is
deeply important to people yeah and you
know Democrats have to go on the
offensive whenever they can just saying
we want to protect the Affordable Care
Act that's not going to encourage people
to get out there if you think that you
know the Republican tax cuts we wish
they hadn't done that that's not gonna
do with this that's not gonna get people
out of the polls so yeah what about this
message what about the message of undo
the Trump tax cuts I think that it's bad
number one because you don't want to
call them the Trump tax cuts because in
the long term they're actually tax
increases for some people because in the
short term they're disproportionately
cuts for the very rich but by saying
repeal the tax cuts you're really
campaigning on
taxes and even if that's what you have
to do even if that's the right thing to
do even if it's just a return to a prior
tax rate right it's not really raising
them it's just going back to a prior
level the optics of it aren't gonna be
good and it's way easier for Republicans
to attack Democrats if they say repeal
the Trump tax cuts or the Trump tax
fiasco or whatever Medicare for all is a
much more positive message and that's
really what I think is a key element of
how Democrats should campaign for 2018
and 2020 it has to be a positive message
so whether or not you believe Obama's
hope and change was BS and many of you
believe it was total BS and in some ways
it was total BS there were changes but
there was also sort of a reconfirmation
or a strengthening or or of a
maintaining of the neoliberal status quo
put that aside for a second it was a
positive message it was a message that
inspired people to go out and vote for
something good Bush ran a disastrous
first term and in 2004 not being Bush
did not work for John Kerry you could
say well hold on a second irregularities
in Ohio maybe it did maybe didn't put
that aside it wasn't clearly an
overwhelming win for John Kerry and
Bush's approval rating was a disaster
and being not Bush didn't work then it
likely will not work against Trump and I
think that that's why whatever the
message is it has to be a positive
message rather than a we are not Trump
message because historically that tends
not to work ok one more idea yeah free
public college education is it too out
there for most people I mean anything
you are a middle-class family trying to
put a few kids through school yeah that
would be an exciting option for you and
something you have to consider if you're
young you just turned 18 you're voting
for the first time yep maybe that would
inspire you to get out and vote in the
midterms if you're past college and you
don't have kids if your kids are past
college or not going to college or you
view college as liberal indoctrination
why do you want tax money to go towards
that right so that's why I think
Medicare for all has much broader appeal
because with the exception of people who
are already on actual Medicare it's
pretty easy to understand how paying
more in taxes
to cover health insurance and getting
rid of health insurance premiums and
co-pays and deductibles and coinsurance
that's a win for way more people than
free college I think we got it
expect the Blue Wave to happen
imminently yeah if people actually go
out and vote and and I hope I hope you
will I hope you will go out and vote in
November